I am Astro Bot.
Astro Bot.
I hit every single can!
Don't fall off, little bots!
Astro Bot.
Can you guys hear it, by the way?
Can you hear it?
Can you hear the audio?
Can you hear me?
Ping-pong-ping.
Yeah?
Again?
Okay, good.
Welcome back, Master!
Master!
Welcome back to...
Welcome back to Astro Bot!
Oh my gosh.
Cinderoth!
Cinderoth, a little thank you!
Oh, you guys can't hear it.
Thank you so much for the Akadono!
Happy...
Astro Bot.
I'm holding it like a kid would hold an actual plane.
You know?
Like a...
I'm not holding it like a controller.
I'm like...
Oh yeah.
The game is a tiny bit louder than me.
Am I quiet?
Maybe.
Happy Friday, everybody!
I'm gonna press a button.
Our save data.
I've been listening to this song for quite a minute, so I kinda wanna...
You!
Welcome back!
Lampy!
Thanks for the gift!
Did it just say Minto Bot?
This game is personalized to me.
Fri-yay!
Happy Fri-yay, everybody!
I hope...
I hope that you are all doing well!
And if you're not doing well, that's okay too.
I hope that you...
Um...
I hope that maybe the stream can cheer you up a little bit.
Or we can just kind of chill with some fun astro buddies.
And, uh...
Yeah!
Hi!
Entry goes next to the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Certain announcement has me feeling down.
I know.
I, uh...
I don't wanna talk so much about it.
It's not really my place to.
Um...
But, uh...
You know...
Um...
I think...
Uh...
If...
Someone is Hiroshi...
And...
They...
Make a big announcement...
That maybe is more of a negative thing...
I think you should trust in Hiroshi.
And...
Them doing what is best for them.
Um...
You know...
Trust that...
Whatever decision that they've made...
Is...
You know...
Like I said, best for them.
And...
Um...
You know...
Despite how hard, how difficult it might be.
Um...
But...
Yeah.
Uh...
Like I said, it's not really my place...
To...
Comment on it.
I...
Um...
But...
Definitely will be a big...
Hole...
Left.
I think.
Um...
Yeah...
But, like I said...
Let's, uh...
Let's just have a fun time.
Chill time.
And...
Be excited for the weekend.
Excited that...
This weekend...
Becomes fall.
And...
With fall...
Comes...
Halloween.
And...
With fall...
Comes...
Nice weather.
And...
With fall...
At least in the Northern Hemisphere.
Sorry if you're in the Southern Hemisphere.
And it comes...
Uh...
And...
And also...
Um...
Uh...
Pumpkin Pie!
And...
Yippee!
It's spring here.
Well, when spring comes...
April showers...
And they...
Uh...
Wait...
That doesn't really work.
Uh...
October showers bring November flowers.
Yeah!
Yay!
Pumpkin Pie!
Oh my god!
Mariah Carey is defrosting.
She's defrosting.
But...
She...
Is...
Not...
Frozen.
Free...
Yet...
We have Halloween to get through.
Been a bit of a rough year, but I'm...
Not here for that.
I'm here for Metal GearBots.
Yeah!
That sounds wrong.
Well...
I mean...
Typically, April showers brings the May flowers.
Do they say that because of the May flower?
Christopher Columbus?
And with fall comes the 10th anniversary of War for the Garden...
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Did you guys see?
That...
They almost tried to take over the garden wall off of Hulu.
And then even...
Even the creator of...
The creator of Gravity Falls is like, what the F are you guys doing?
Apparently, they...
Apparently, it's not getting taken off now, which is...
I don't know.
I only saw one tweet that someone said it's not leaving now.
Oh, Mayflower is the pilgrim.
So...
Why are you guys still watching?
What is that?
I've been dead for a while.
I don't really care about human history, okay?
It's literally saying rain helps grow flowers.
Yeah!
But there's also...
The Mayflower!
Which what even is that?
Oh!
But yeah, so... I guess Hulu is not getting rid of Over the Garden Wall, which means we can watch it!
Yippee!
Yippee yippee yippee!
Over the Garden Wall is safe as of today.
Yeah.
Hopefully.
Why would you take it down anyway?
Great show.
Isadora, welcome to Memboshoop!
Sobri, thanks for 30 months!
And Raylord, welcome to Memboshoop!
Thank you!
Cool!
So... I guess there's not really a story in this for it to be like, last time we did this, but...
I'm so excited for Minto Bot Friday.
Minto...
...Bot Friday?
Did you guys see that Earth is temporarily gonna get a second moon?
I think it's only for like, one day.
Kinda crazy.
What's going on?
What if this... Does that mean the moon will be in...
Renegade?
Uh...
Gatorade?
Happens every now and then.
That's crazy.
Why can't it stay?
I want a second moon!
That's so, like...
That's so...
Fan... Not fantasy novel.
Like, dystopian novel.
That's so... Young adult dystopian novel.
Yeah, very sci-fi.
I want it to stay!
I wonder how that would affect... the tides.
Moon NTR?
Nooo...
Moonfall?
Yeah, we need more moons.
More moons, more moons, more moons.
That would be awesome.
Blow up the moon and make two moons!
No, I think, you know...
We could just start collecting moons.
Eventually, we won't even see the sun.
We'll have so many moons.
Around, uh... around, uh... planet Earth.
I do love a good full moon.
Yeah, but what if you had two full moons?
Oh, yeah!
Both double-cheeked up!
What's better than one moon?
Two full moons!
On a Friday afternoon?
On a Friday evening, even.
I must trauma-dump.
What is this?
I was making chili lime chicken and I ran out of...
Chug water chili powder.
What's chug water?
What's so special about that?
So I went to the store to buy some more...
And they're charging $11!
I cried, but my chicken is now cooking.
Oh!
Sorry, ducky, I missed yours.
Time to start your own history with the minto flower.
What is a chug water chili powder?
Is that just a brand?
DJ!
Thanks for the popcorn!
I saw a clip of Astrobot where Kinryu Kazuma was featured.
Perfect timing with the latest Ryuga Gotoku game announcement.
The pirate one, right?
Oh my gosh, I gotta get my butt in gear and play Yakuza.
I gotta play Yakuza.
I gotta play Devil May Cry.
I was thinking after...
Maybe...
After Eternal Darkness...
Once I'm back home, maybe I'll do...
I'll start the DMC.
Maybe, maybe.
We get a temporary new moon and a temporary new star this month.
What?
I didn't hear about the star.
No way.
Yakuza sold your game.
But I thought maybe doing Devil May Cry because it would be shorter.
I think I have to...
I have to...
I have to start Yakuza once I'm done, done with the Metal Gear series.
You know what I mean?
Because I really want to dedicate time to it.
Yeah, it's much shorter.
So...
That's kind of where my brain is at.
Yakuza is now...
Wait.
Was it like yesterday?
International pirate...
Talk like a pirate day?
I wonder...
That's why they announced it.
Yakuza.
Okay.
All right.
I'm done talking.
Let's go visit our bots real quick.
Let's go visit our bots real quick and see how they're doing.
Oh my gosh.
Crash jump scare.
Oh, the way they salute is so cute.
So these are all our bots so far.
Oh my gosh.
This guy is doing...
What the gay?
Well...
Not really.
Oh my gosh.
This Waza is so advanced.
No.
Ma.
Su.
He's doing his best.
He's still learning.
Yeah.
Airplane directing?
No.
Hi snake.
Hi Oh my gosh.
When I get close to him I just realized my controller actually started rumbling.
Chug water is a place in Wyoming.
It's a very small podunk town.
There's about 175 people in it.
You guys.
I think we need to go to chug water and take it over.
Can we take over a chug water?
Chug Water, Wyoming.
I think we can have a revolution there.
They make the best chili and their chili powder is great for chicken.
Let's go take over Chug Water!
I have to remember the controls.
What was circle?
Okay, so we have to jump obviously.
Oh yes, hold it.
Nikki,
I hope I said your name right.
Thanks for the podcasting!
It's bite time.
Oh sorry, Snake.
I'm beating him up.
Snake, don't forget your magazine.
What is he doing in there?
This is not the love box.
And we got some... we had the gacha.
We opened this up.
Right?
I don't think I have any more though.
Gachala!
Oh wait!
It's a hundred.
Oh, it's empty!
It's empty.
Okay, that's right.
We bought all of it.
That's right.
Let's go.
Oh, wait a second.
There's some more things here.
Do these replenish?
Hey, open up!
Cool, cool, cool.
And then there was this one.
Oh, that's right.
We need to sacrifice our men.
Cool.
Wait a second.
Is this guy stuck?
Oh my god!
Help him!
How do I grab again?
Okay, there we go.
Oh my god!
Poor thing!
What do we get?
Oh, he's in...
Why are you making that face at him?
Can't say I've seen this maid cafe before.
Why are you see-through?
Oh, don't worry about it!
Oh my gosh, I wonder if I can spell something.
Uh... I!
N!
T!
Okay.
I guess that... I don't know what that did.
Oh, sorry.
That was... It's an aggressive pet.
Keith, thank you!
Alright, let's go.
Let's go to another level.
Wait, how do I... Sorry, hold on.
I'm remembering how to play.
Oh, it was right-left trigger.
I'm pretty sure...
Ah!
Okay.
There's clearly still more here.
Quite a bit, actually.
Let's enter.
Oh, yes!
Yes, yes!
How could I forget?
What's this up here?
No, no, no.
Oh!
What are you?
Oi!
Wah!
Alex, thank you for five months!
Wow!
It's Pyrobug!
Thank you for the 20 gift card!
Where do we want to go?
I guess we gotta go to...
New York City!
Holy cow, there's a ton of guys here.
Brr, brr, brr!
Ah!
Oh!
Oh my gosh, we're gonna slip!
Ah!
Yeah!
Take that!
Free the bananas!
Free the nanas!
Time to go banana crazy!
Wah!
Yeah!
Banana, we're going bananas, if you could say.
Oh!
Ah!
Ape escape!
Oh!
Power!
I'm coming for you, monkey!
Yah!
I ain't got time on you!
Wait, L2?
Oh, it's, it's, okay, it's like detecting...
I'm just, I'm, I'm a serial killer!
I'm playing with his head like he's a...
Like he's, he's my toy!
What do I do with you?
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Oh, sorry.
Oh, R2!
Thank you!
Wait, where'd he go?
Ah!
I don't think he want...
Oh, he's so scary.
Look at him.
I don't think he wanted to be rescued.
Hi, everybody!
This is how I can wave at you guys.
Hi!
Don't mind the monkey.
This is how I can wave at you guys.
You can see me waving.
Ah!
Hi!
Gets incredibly anxious around nets.
Oh!
Woo!
What if I don't catch him?
Oh!
He's got magnetic powers.
Okay.
There's gotta be more in here though, right?
There's gotta be more coins and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
There's gotta be more that I missed.
What about this guy over here?
Technically, this is still Metal Gear.
Yes, it is!
You must capture all the monkeys.
Okay.
Cheggie, you got your nose.
Put!
Try it.
Ty, I'm using this net on you.
Capture all the monkeys.
Can I get you?
Aw, he's just snoozing.
He's snoozing.
Metal Gear adjacent.
It counts.
It counts, it counts, it counts.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I actually have to capture all the monkeys.
Come here!
Monkey number two secured.
Actually, why are there so many?
Tony Hawk Pro Skater!
Whoa!
Sick!
Sick moves.
Or Sonic.
Oh.
Oh!
Mm, monkey.
Monkey.
Nice.
And there's some more coins in here.
Beat em up, beat em up, beat em up, beat em up!
The music in this level is so fun.
Secret.
Is this guy okay?
Okay.
This doesn't look like New York.
It's only the statue of a monkey.
I want to capture the bugs!
This feels like Animal Crossing.
This whole soundtrack is so bubbly.
Yeah!
So fun.
Love it.
Oh.
Uh.
If I forget a control.
Just remind me.
Don't feel like you are like, Hey Minto.
Minto, you remember you can do this?
It's a-okay if you're like, hey Minto!
Don't forget to do this!
Four little monkeys in a controller.
The three apes you caught have different descriptions.
Oh!
It's just another Manic Monday!
That's my fun day!
Oh no, what did the other one say?
I missed it.
Like this guy.
I like how it's gearing up where...
Oh!
Something's gonna happen at the top.
Don't forget you can be cute and wave to us.
Hi!
I don't know about the first part.
Oh!
That's right!
I can pull!
What was it?
Circle or square?
Square!
I know what I need to do!
Love the monkey!
Come here little monkey.
Yeah.
Come here.
Come here monkey.
Don't run from me monkey.
I don't think these bots want to be rescued.
I don't think they...
I don't think I'm rescuing them at all.
Oh!
You caught on to my plan monkey!
He's a fast guy.
I'm gonna blow you up.
I'm gonna throw TNT on you.
Yeah!
Five little monkeys in a controller.
How many...
could...
you hold...
hold...
I'm workshopping it, okay guys?
I'm workshopping it.
Nice!
We have some sort of ape escape.
That's... that would be... no.
What are you talking about?
Ape escape?
I can choose between beef bok choy stir fry or chicken foot curry for dinner.
Had stir fry, so if you want to become Minto, you can also have stir fry.
He to be Minto is having stir fry.
Taking notes.
Six little monkeys in a controller.
Such a way with words.
Take your time.
I'm working on it!
We become Minto, can I still shower and put deodorant or do I...
No!
What?
That's what I do all the time!
Don't believe Matara's lies.
Okay.
We're gonna go up there, obviously.
But we have...
Look at this guy.
What the...
What is he...
Who is he slapping?
Oh my gosh.
I had him right there.
Where did he go?
I'm chasing him blindly.
Oh.
Monkey!
I don't think he was...
Seven little monkeys in a controller.
Though one fell out and...
Did a holler.
Wait, how's the original go?
Five little monkeys jumping on the bed.
One fell out and bumped his head.
What's the rest?
One fell out and broke their shoulders.
Oh my gosh.
We're not trying to...
We're not trying to kill them.
My goshi.
I'm good.
The mama called the doctor and the doctor said, no more monkeys jumping on the bed.
I remember now.
I remember.
Hold on.
Let's grab some of this other stuff that's around here.
Oh.
Stop.
You sucker.
All right.
Oh, shoot.
Even though I just killed that guy.
Forgot about him.
All right.
Dead.
I'll get them one of these.
This is the worst game of Animal Crossing ever.
What does this thing do?
Looks like the Discord symbol.
Oh.
This is the one that makes you fly.
Wait.
How does it work again?
Oh.
Okay.
It's quite fast.
I'm trying to...
I can't even see it.
Wahoo.
Weehee.
Okay.
Here we go.
What the?
Why is it telling me to L2?
Hold on.
I'm not ready.
Double jump.
Okay.
Oh.
Sorry.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
How did I use it?
I think it was square.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh.
Because it's...
Ah!
Come here, monkey.
Oh.
I don't want to fall.
Hmm.
Oh.
Come here, monkey.
I've got to be the fastest there ever was.
Easy-peasy.
Eight little monkeys in a controller.
One fell out and broke his shoulder.
The doctor...
Mama called the doctor.
Wait.
Minto called the doctor and the doctor said, keep on shaking the monkeys in the controller.
The doctor's orders, you guys.
I'm just kidding.
No, I'm not kidding.
I'm not kidding.
What's that?
Oh.
It's...
My
depth perception!
I can't tell if these are even captureable because I'm so bad at it.
It's like the golden snitch.
Oh my gosh.
You would think I...
Oh.
Oh net profit!
I got a trophy for it and everything.
Let's go.
Do you think I can capture this thing?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, have I just been bad this whole time?
No...
Beep boop.
Monkey!
It's dangerous!
Oh my god.
Monkey, you can't be like that!
It's so scary!
Oh my gosh, Monkey.
What a thrill.
Yeah, that's right.
How many are in here now?
Not even sure how they got up here.
Skywalking it.
Oh, I keep forgetting to read it because they're all the same.
Whee!
Nice.
So just one monkey left!
Do you think he's up there?
Oh.
I think so.
I think we found our prime ape.
Oh my gosh, I've just been bad this whole time.
I'm telling you guys, I have... You would think I have an eyepatch on.
With my dead perception.
You would think...
You would think I have an eyepatch on.
Oh gosh.
There we go.
That means I missed so many coins from before!
Hattori!
Welcome to Mavenship.
Thank you so much.
I hope you enjoy your stay.
I hope you have better depth perception than me.
Thank you.
Thanks for waiting.
I'll be back.
See you.
I'm getting dizzy.
Naruto?
Mothership's memory.
Spectre?
Fight, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight!
Fish and mild.
I ran out of juice just at the last second.
They're fast.
There we go.
Take
that!
Oh my gosh.
I gotta capture him, I think.
He's out of breath.
He's out of...
He was out of...
He's out of breath!
Who's this guy?
Albino antagonist.
The naughtiest monkey!
Naughty monkey, yo.
I think I'm the naughtiest monkey.
Yay, we got a ship pod!
Nice.
Whoa.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Isn't there supposed to be like a special thing that pops up?
I'm not gonna go.
Come on.
Isn't there gonna be like a coin or something?
No?
Oh.
Okay!
Yes, you are.
Thank you.
You are now ready for snake versus monkey.
Oh.
I like how all the monkeys are like watching us.
You rescued the mothership's memory.
This song is awesome.
It's in no use in this condition.
Oh.
Look!
I'm controlling it!
It's no use in this condition though.
Let's repair it!
Okay, what do I do?
Put that in?
Is this the...
Okay, I'm fixing it, I'm fixing it...
Okay, slowly...
Oh!
Nice, it did it all on its own.
And... one big one, one big one.
Hi Snake!
Snake!
Can you see me?
Watch this, Snake.
This one's for you.
This is so fun!
Oh, more, more.
Okay, okay.
Snake!
Snake is so impressed!
Oh my god!
Did you see me with the hard eyes?
Be careful, be careful of your...
FINGERS!
Okay, here we go.
And... you!
They corrected it?
God, I wish that were me.
What am I doing?
Like...
Like this?
Oh, it still works.
You can't mess it up, you guys.
There's only one way you can do it.
I'm like, really schmoving my body right now.
I'm really schmoving my body right now.
I should have played this with 3D.
Here we go.
Ah!
I think she was kicking her feet while she was...
Stop!
Wow!
Our box!
I like the design.
I like the design on it.
Cool.
And it... oh, so we need four of them.
Why the hard eyes though?
Unforgettable!
Yay!
Oh, because I was still moving my arms around.
Oh my god, it's doxing my age.
Just kidding.
And we got a couple new puzzle pieces.
Nice!
Oh!
Hag!
Is this thing in real time?
I don't know.
It stopped aging a long time ago.
Oh, he's there.
Snake, what do you want to show me?
What do you want to show me?
What do you want to show me, Snake?
Gray Fox is stuck in the well?
Oh no!
We need 25 guys to help us with this.
Oh gosh, it's a monkey ladder.
Wait, do I have to walk across it?
Wait, is Snake in here?
Is that him over there?
Yeah, I see him in the middle.
Excuse me!
Sorry!
Oh, I forgot something.
Never mind.
I found it in my pocket.
Sorry.
Hold on.
Oh, you gotta go to the bathroom.
Never mind.
I'll just wait.
Oh!
My mom's calling me.
Never mind.
Leah!
Thank you for the braid!
Sorry, I'm...
I'm being a little...
I'm being normal right now.
Mostly.
Wow, a whole new area!
Oh my gosh, our guy is trapped over there.
Look!
Hey, why are there enemies on our...
Oh, you guys just followed me.
It's dangerous!
Go back!
Can you go back?
He didn't step on my face.
Okay, well soon.
I'll never...
How'd you like that?
You're impressed?
You're quite impressed?
These poor guys!
They're stuck in jail!
I'm totally fine.
I'm totally normal.
Also, hi everybody!
I'm playing Astro Bot.
It's so cute.
It's so awesome.
It's so fun.
Oh, dread.
Okay.
Okay, just drop down.
This guy is trying to escape.
No!
You must join!
You must join the other bots!
You're not allowed to leave.
Okay, there's a lot we can do here.
Wow!
Hello monkeys!
This game is kind of really awesome.
Yeah!
I'm zapping your butts.
They're monkeys.
Stop being so pretentious.
Haruka!
Thank you for the gift!
Arigato!
Hello?
Gosh, the way they all shuffle over.
Oh my goodness.
This doesn't seem very... Why did I need 20 of you guys?
Oh, there's something down there.
I'm scared though.
I'm scared.
Oh my gosh, why is he looking like that?
He's like, don't look at my skirt, cat!
Okay, we're going down.
I got a creative cursor.
Make your dreams come true.
Where is this guy from?
Beamers are still kind of monkeys.
Yeah, you guys!
They're still monkeys.
Dreams.
From dreams.
Okay, we're done!
You guys are good now.
You guys are all...
They wait my next order.
Where's Snake?
Oh, he's over here.
You didn't want to help me out?
That's fine.
What's this?
Excuse me.
You're free!
She's never freeing those four.
They'll come out eventually.
I have other impressing matters.
I want to get all these other ones first.
Like this one.
Hello!
What are we doing here?
Oh...
Oh!
And you!
Boing!
Oh!
Another...
Spyro!
Oh my god!
He's so cute!
Fiery artisan!
Last spotted in the sky!
Spyro!
I love Spyro so much!
Alright!
Yeah!
Oh no!
That guy's getting harassed!
I'm coming!
I love Spyro!
Oh!
What the?
Wait!
What just happened?
I went away too far.
Okay, my bad.
Do it again!
Oh my god!
Snake is on the bottom!
Okay, Snake!
I'm gonna... I'm gonna climb!
Snake!
I'm gonna climb!
Noooo!
Literal wall climber.
Ow!
Oh!
Sorry!
Wait!
No!
I
didn't...
I...
I was like...
Why are you just standing there?
I didn't know!
I didn't...
You
killed a child!
That's why you're the best boss!
I didn't know!
Are you gonna find new places for us to go to?
Woah!
The taco way!
Nice!
Wait!
Hold on though!
Do you think he's really gone?
Do you think he's really dead?
Rip those four.
Well, I'm gonna go get them right now.
I'm gonna go get them right now.
Yes.
I'm faster than you, Snake.
I'm faster than you.
Spyro!
Why didn't you salute me?
Ow!
Oh my gosh.
Let's stay crisp.
I feel so...
Excuse me!
Who's shaking?
Who's gyrating right here?
Psycho Mantis!
Of course you would be.
What a freak.
Nice whistling.
I know, I'm a pretty good whistler.
Me too!
See, we have 52.
52 out of 300.
Oh wait!
We can do this one now!
Oh my gosh, awesome!
Awesome!
Now we need another 20?
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Okay, there's a guy in here.
We got...
Oh my gosh!
Amaterasu!
Celestial Painter!
The physical incarnation of a god!
So freaky.
Oh, that's it.
Oh wait, there's nothing else up here?
Nope, just some monkeys.
Okamiya!
Wow!
There's so many games in here that I didn't expect to see.
The one over here was 50, right?
There's also that puzzle piece up there.
Or, I'm sorry, this was 100, right?
How
do we get to this one?
I'm assuming it's from up here?
The flowers make noises?
So cute!
Ta-da!
Uh, wait!
Oh, wait!
I can't get up there?
Oh, wait.
Oh?
So, never mind, it must be...
...somehow.
How?
Poor guy on the wall.
Can I get him?
Maybe from here.
Oh!
Oh, maybe it's the 100 is for the tree.
Ok, we'll wait then.
You're part of my party, right?
Yeah.
Ok, good.
Ta-da-da!
No!
Wow!
Ok.
I don't think there was anything else that...
Oh my gosh, so cute!
They're fine!
They're fine.
Oh my gosh, he has his own little, like, army.
What are you...
Oh, he wants the gacha.
Ok, let's go do more gacha, you guys.
Ta-da!
Oh,
yes!
Yes!
I'm grabbing you.
Alright.
Ha!
Noise generator!
Just beat it!
Beat it!
Next.
Mastermind's throne!
Take over the world in comfort and...
Oh!
In comfort and style!
Cute.
Keep those grabby hands away from me.
Oh, I can't grab anymore.
It's not letting me.
Ha!
Summer essential...
Look at how chill this guy is.
The most chill monkey...
Oh!
Oh my god, he's dead.
I was gonna grab you guys.
Ha!
For great...
Oh my gosh, thank you, monkey.
Wow!
He's so wise.
Sorry.
Just a box!
Blend in box 3000.
I love this game!
Oh no, I don't have enough.
Okay, we'll have to go get more coins, everybody.
Missile gear.
So cute!
Every monkey gets a little special thing.
Oh, it locked up.
So cute!
No!
He's like, hey!
Hey!
Trying to monkey around here.
Oh!
You okay?
He's fine.
Yeah!
It's literally the same animation, but with the monkey.
It's so funny.
Press triangle?
What's triangle do?
Oh!
Everybody's here!
Why are you so obsessed with me, huh?
Why are you so obsessed with me?
Get to the back of the line!
Push through all of them to get to Snake.
Snake!
I'm here.
Grey Fox.
Psycho Mantis.
We need more money.
D-pad also does stuff?
No way.
Spyro is killing me.
Why is he just like...
Spyro!
It's a dance party!
Spyro can't do anything.
He's just like convulsing.
Did I turn around and you guys started to floss?
Don't start jumping up and down for that.
Oh my god.
Stop it.
Hey you.
Look at Spyro trying to floss.
And then Dream is just like...
Oh my gosh!
Look at the monkeys are killing me.
This world is so funny.
I love this.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, I just noticed Amaterasu over here.
Why don't you come join us?
Okay, let's all dance now!
That was silly.
I can't get over Spyro being...
Just not being able to do anything.
Okay.
Too regal, yeah.
Clearly.
Let's go do more levels.
The god does not dance.
I don't think there was anything else...
I could do here yet, so...
Was there...
Did I get everything in here?
Well, clearly not.
But...
Oh, we still have just a few...
Robots.
But I am curious what's in Taco World.
Just like Fortnite.
Oh my god!
Eww!
Stop!
Oh my gosh, how rude!
Crab.
Big bad.
So rude.
Go, go!
Archipelago!
Connie.
Oh.
Woah.
Ouch.
So close!
We're gonna have to come back.
Oh my gosh.
Even the guys are on...
They're just on break.
Look at them.
They don't want to fight me.
They just want to be on vacation.
Right?
Oh.
You guys just want to be on vacation.
Yeah.
Take that.
This guy is really living his life.
This guy
is really living his life.
Oh, I can swim.
I thought I would die in the water.
For real.
Can I actually swim-swim?
Oh.
Chill, BJ.
I'm so chill.
I know, I feel...
I feel really chill right now.
I'm not gonna lie.
Let's get that turtle.
I feel so chill right now, for real.
Oh.
Oh, hold on.
Oh, wait, hold on.
My turn.
Oh.
Oh, I did it.
Ow.
Stop.
Let me go through the hole.
Little baby turtles.
This is so cute.
Happy family.
They're so cute.
Nice.
Let me in.
Ow.
Oh.
Ah.
Not bad.
No way.
I started at the beginning.
Guys.
Get good.
Or else you pay the price.
I'm getting this guy first.
Oh, no.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
They have eye patches.
Oh, they're so cute.
I got it, guys.
I'm just a regular guy.
Lizard.
Take him home.
That was definitely solidus.
Yeah.
Oh.
Minto depth perception strikes again.
Not a single...
Not a single one.
Oh, my gosh.
Minto depth perception strikes.
Oh.
Again.
Yeah.
I missed one.
Should I try again?
I think I won't be satisfied until I get all of it.
You know?
Again?
Okay.
Give me a second.
We were here.
Let's get all this first and everything.
Remember?
Yeah.
There we go.
Let's collect all our stuff that we...
That we...
Because we died.
Think of the gacha.
Yeah.
We'll get it.
Don't worry.
Oh.
Is there anything over here?
How far can I go?
No one knows.
How far out goes.
Oh.
I forgot it was this guy.
Nice.
How do I get up here?
How do I get to you?
Glad we...
I don't have like a...
Oxygen meter.
Maybe from above.
Or maybe I can just run and jump.
Easy.
Give me your weasel.
Oh no.
He's abandoning the weasel.
Karaoke ended.
Oh.
No one knows.
I'm gonna destroy your house.
So you'll never come back.
Okay?
You'll never feel a need to...
To wanna live here again.
Destroy.
Eco-terrorism.
Yeah.
Now this guy will never be like.
Aw man.
I missed my shell house.
No you don't.
It's destroyed.
There's nothing left of it.
Punch.
Hi.
My name is Kathy.
This is my house.
Isn't it ours?
No.
Cause it's destroyed.
Okay.
What's this?
Secret.
Oh.
Maybe I should die.
Restart.
She lost the gacho.
I think I was just...
I think I might do it like this.
It'd be better.
Min, did you just quote Vermillion?
Wow.
You got the reference.
Yay!
Oh.
Sorry little turtles.
Sorry.
Oh.
I also have to jump through the hoop.
Sorry.
Oh.
I also have to jump through the hoop.
Sorry.
Oh.
I also have to jump through the hoop.
Wait.
Biki my shell.
How do I defeat this guy again?
That's right.
There we go.
What was it?
Please remind me.
Game.
I don't remember what to do.
I gotta do a swirly.
Oh I gotta power up.
I gotta power up.
I got
an actual monkey!
Oh my gosh.
Oh an actual monkey.
What?
Oh no.
Oh.
How do I move my arm?
How do I move my...
Oh.
Okay.
Oh wow!
Go go!
Oh you are actual monkeys.
You're not little robot friends.
Tilt the controller.
Yeah.
It's kinda weird.
Oh.
My bad.
Okay.
Monkey backpack.
Can I just beat you up?
I tickle you till you open.
Oh I gotta.
Oh I gotta grip him.
Nah!
And we gotta grab these.
And we gotta...
Grippers!
These are some monkey claws.
Okay we got a couple more to throw.
Can't miss.
I have one more though.
What am I supposed to throw it at?
Who's my victim?
The birds?
Must be right?
Who am I to throw this at?
I'm just gonna take it with me as a little souvenir I guess.
Oh.
I missed?
Hey!
Uh.
We have ranged attacks now!
Yeah!
This is some real monkey business.
Let's get this guy too.
Did we lose?
No!
No we haven't even lost one.
Kind of awesome.
Where?
Oh.
And they respawn!
Come on!
Aww yeah baby!
Good.
Nice.
Yes everybody.
Oh I think I need to use my hands here.
Hands!
Oh!
And this guy is also...
There's a little guy in there!
You're welcome!
Yes.
I'm taking this with me.
Who is that in there?
I see...
Oh wow there's so much around here.
Oh my gosh look how cute!
The little symbols in the water!
What?
That's so cute!
Break the glass?
No I know what we need to do.
I gotta use my arms.
Wait.
How do I get that up there?
Monkey!
Just climb higher!
Just go up!
Wait.
I think I need to shoot this monkey into the tree.
Use the rock.
Where do I put the rock?
Oh there it is.
You guys it...
It didn't work.
That's okay.
How am I supposed to aim up?
Oh I don't think I can use this to go down.
That's a shame.
How can I just go down though?
Should I just jump down I wonder?
We'll see if we go down from here.
Pew!
And then I see over there there's some stuff as well.
Smash the bridge?
Well hold on.
We got stuff in here first.
We got stuff in here.
We got our monkey...
Monkey!
Mon...
Maybe... oh.
See there's more.
Gosh there's so much to explore.
There's so much to explore.
Oh my gosh!
I did something.
Oh!
That's how we get over there.
Oh my gosh be careful.
Every nook and cranny.
I know.
This world is crazy.
There's so much in here.
Nice!
Use my grippers?
And then... gripper?
Gripper?
Gripper.
What is this?
Do I grip?
Wait I
think I got a job.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I'm actually so good?
Who said I'm not a gamer?
Who said?
What the hell is this?
Horned protector.
Stick to the shadows.
Who is this?
It was me.
Sorry!
Aiko.
Shadow of the Colossus.
Oh!
Maybe that was supposed to get him down.
My bad.
Maybe that was how I was supposed to do that puzzle.
No worries.
So let's go back down here.
Can I even do it here?
Down.
Oh my god!
How is this possible?
Ah!
They're scared!
They're alone and they're scared!
They're naked and afraid!
Winky physics.
Do you think I can go through here?
Aha!
This is how I don't die.
Hello!
Elfin prisoner.
Needs to be led by the hand.
Yorda?
I don't know this one either.
Oh!
Aloha!
Oh my gosh!
The trees!
We have such a cool monkey!
Oh my gosh!
Aloha!
Nice.
Aiko.
Am I saying it right?
Or is it like ICO?
Am I saying it correct?
Wow!
Aloha!
What do I do with this guy?
Hmm...
Oh my gosh!
We're slow.
What do I do with...
Oh!
I see!
Nice!
The ICO is silent.
Oh!
It's... Oh, so their name is...
I got you.
Which one is it?
Oh!
This one!
Push...
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
You almost died in here!
For real!
Oh!
Wait.
Where did the skeleton go?
Oh!
Where?
I smashed it!
Oh!
Toasty!
So cute!
Such good attention to detail in this game.
Awesome!
Okay, so we have one bot left.
We're gonna have to come back though for the puzzle piece.
Wait, what's over here?
Nothing.
Sorry, it was really bright.
Oh!
Now
we can continue our work!
I didn't mean to destroy the skeleton.
Oh wait!
I forgot about...
This one too.
I want the coins.
Give me the coins!
Wait though.
We still haven't discovered how to get this chest out of the...
Greedy ghost!
Isn't it okay if Minto is greedy?
Just a little bit?
Just a little?
What is this?
Oh!
Woah!
Just...
Just a little as a treat?
Yippee!
Maybe we can get to it...
From up there.
You think?
I want that box.
Clearly it's special, you know?
Use your monkey powers.
We're gonna run out of...
We're gonna run...
Oh no!
Ah!
We got it!
Alright, we're never...
Oh my gosh, it's a pop-up pirate game.
A pop-up pirate game.
Yay!
I think that's all of them.
Isn't it?
Yippee!
We got them all!
Nice.
Okay.
Very good.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Woah!
Oh!
Oh my god.
I forgot to jump.
My bad.
Is he...
Oh, okay.
We still got him.
Fish and mail.
No, no.
We're okay.
Spooked me though, for real.
Oh my gosh.
Woah!
Oh, he's like walking around even!
Hey!
Oh my gosh!
Got him.
Got his butt.
Platformers.
Okay, okay.
Here we go.
Oh!
Kind of a genius.
Ah!
Oh!
Is there anything that looks like I missed?
Clearly we missed a secret portal.
And we missed...
I know I missed one...
What's this?
By the skull.
On the top right.
There's an X.
What does it mean?
Treasure map.
Um...
I know I missed the one puzzle piece at the very beginning.
Cause I...
Um...
I
know I missed the one.
Maybe there's one more later on.
Cause it's...
We got the second one.
This is kind of tricky.
You can move the other hand on the same...
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Reach!
Reach monkey!
Here I was like hard-moding it.
For real.
I was making it so much harder than it is.
Yeah!
What's this though?
Oh!
Do I need this?
Nope.
Got that.
Self-imposed handicap.
I know.
Look, I like a challenge, okay?
Even if I have to create it myself.
Yeah!
Oh, okay, I get it.
Oh!
Wait!
This is the skull!
It's on the top right.
Wait, in his eye?
His eye looks like it can be cracked, right?
Oh, nice.
Hold on, let's get to the top first.
Why'd the music stop?
Maybe there.
Wait.
Why'd the music stop?
Hold on.
Wait, can I...
Dig!
Boss time.
But what about the secret?
What about the secret, you guys?
I wasted too much trouble on it and it's not completable.
Wait, what do you... Oh!
I can't complete...
Oh!
No!
Really?
Oh my gosh, I almost fell off.
Minto falling off.
Oh my god.
Captain Pinscher!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Wait, I just died?
Wait, how did I just die?
I thought it was a cutscene.
That's so funny.
Oh, I lost my rock.
Okay.
Yeah, it was too cinematic, for real.
Wait, so...
Oh, I guess I don't need that.
Yeah, it does have a bit of a range.
Yeah, right?
Oh, okay, okay, I see now, I see.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Let's wait for it to come back down.
What does that do?
Oh, it allows me to climb.
Gross.
Whoa!
Oh, close!
I need to be faster, maybe.
No!
Come here.
So close.
Oh, dang it, I threw it too far.
Oh, I'm throwing these all in the worst spots.
Oh!
Oh, he's juggling!
They respawn, it's okay, it's okay.
He's so awesome.
Oh, and they also disappear, so...
That's fine.
Oh,
I missed it.
There we go.
Use the Stinger, my souls!
Okay.
Whee!
Jump up on the Hydra's back!
Oh my gosh.
How am I supposed to...
time this?
Oh my gosh.
Hmm?
Okay.
Yeah!
Nice!
Uh...
Jump up on the Hydra's back!
Where do I kill him?
Oh, I...
The
PTSD from that.
Sorry.
I was having a moment with it.
Oh, no!
Nice.
Yeah, I literally beheaded him, yeah.
Kind of hardcore.
Wow!
So many bananas!
Oh.
We can kill a guy.
Ah!
Yippee!
Wait, what if... No, there wouldn't be another puzzle piece.
Probably.
We know which one that I'm missing.
We know which one I'm missing.
Nice!
If I... Okay, I have a question for anybody who's played this.
If I go back in and get that puzzle piece at the very beginning and then leave, will it be okay?
Can I do that?
Grab it and exit the level?
Yeah, right?
I should be able to do that, right?
Minto wins!
Okay, let's try it.
Okay.
Where's that?
Where's that dang bird?
Yeah,
but the secret...
We can't even do the secret yet.
I don't think it's unlockable, apparently.
Yet so...
I will... What if I crash?
Ah!
Why can't I go any further?
Maybe I... Okay, hold on.
I think I have to reach him.
I have to get him on the right side.
Oh, you can after the boss!
Oh...
Wait, so...
Do I have to redo the boss again?
Or can I do it now?
Oh my gosh, wait!
How do I...
Oh, boost!
Okay, let's try again.
You have to redo the boss.
Well, it wasn't that hard.
Ah, I didn't realize that it was only after the boss.
Oh, what's this?
Bird.
Sorry, I didn't specify.
I didn't want to be too specific.
It's okay, I'm not mad at all.
Don't worry about it.
It's a guide for miss... Oh.
We got all of them.
I didn't really...
I didn't remember what it was.
Let's go here to the trunk of fog.
You know what?
Let's just leave.
Let's just rip me, man.
It's okay.
I'm not even a little bit mad.
Whoa...
Whoa!
Wait, wait, wait!
Nice!
And...
Turkey!
Oh my gosh, a little mole.
He looks so stupid.
He was camping me?
For real?
Oh my god.
There we go.
Oh!
They snipe hard.
Yeah, take that.
This guy is incognito.
He's so funny looking.
Oh my gosh.
I just like pulled out his insides from his butt.
This area is so cute.
It's so chill.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Whoops.
Oh!
Oh, these things are ugly.
Hahaha.
It's okay.
Excuse me!
Oh!
How do
I stop you from being ugly?
Yeah!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Angry flower.
Oh my god, that tree is talking.
Hahaha.
Just to himself.
Talking tree.
This place is kind of weird.
Wow!
That's a lot of nuts.
This place is kind of crazy.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, you're slaves.
They're bringing you water.
These little ants.
Hey!
Get back in line.
Uh oh.
There's a traffic jam, you guys.
Hahaha.
There's a traffic jam.
He's so sad.
Cows and deer and everything.
Steak.
Mint, why?
I don't know.
Hahaha.
Look, they're back to normal.
It's fine.
Mostly.
Oh, I got it.
I got them all in one go.
And I'm so good.
What's this do?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, open up!
Open up!
Does this thing jump up into my mouth?
I didn't know I was playing a horror game.
I'm legit...
I'm sad.
I wasn't...
Oh no, no, no, no, I don't wanna...
Oh no!
Oh god, get me away from him!
I don't wanna look at this tree any longer.
Oh my god, the camera angle is like...
forcing me to look at him.
Oh!
We can play golf!
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
So close.
Okay.
Like this, like this.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, oh, oh.
The Deku Tree was always into war.
I don't like that.
Okay, scoot over a little bit.
The tree is cute!
I don't... I'm terrified.
Oh.
But sometimes I use my right hand, and sometimes I use my left hand.
Let's try.
Oh my god.
Robot.
Oh!
Oh, so close!
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
I should have waited to do this part.
I had no idea what was gonna happen.
It's the Carni...
Carniferous Tree from Mortal Kombat.
Wow.
They have everyone in this game.
Oh, oh, oh.
Who is that over there?
I got you.
Brave biker.
Better a one percenter than a freaker.
What's wrong with being a freaker?
What do you mean by that?
Day is gone.
Isn't that a zombie?
Can I get his butt?
Maybe not.
Unless I'm just bad.
How do I bait him out?
There we go.
Okay, just kidding.
Apples, apples.
Oh my god, the sheep are so cute.
Oh, oh, oh.
Zombie games love making up another word for zombie.
They really do, don't they?
Oh, oh, oh.
You think any of you guys died from the tree growing?
Because zombie is too cliche, you guys.
You gotta say like...
It's crazy.
Mind.
So we're really gonna go into this guy's mouth?
Or...
Oh my god, I'm so scared right now.
And I'm so...
Look at him.
He's literally...
He is losing himself over this guy.
He's like, this tree!
Oh my gosh, tree!
This is robot's time of his life!
We got an elephant!
I think.
That's something.
I can't tell.
Oh!
Uh...
So...
Wait, what?
Oh!
Create extra platforms.
What?
Oh, this is a bad guy.
Does it...
Does it like...
Use up stuff too?
Or...
Like if I use up all the goops...
Like, or...
Did I get all of it?
Actually, I can't tell.
Yes, I did.
Cuz I'm a gamer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow, this one's actually so fun!
Three charges.
Okay, got it, got it.
He's freaking me out, you guys.
Can't get me from up here.
Ow!
He can get me from up there!
Okay.
Oh shit.
Classic.
Okay.
I didn't think I could make it.
And that's why I had made the other platform earlier.
But...
Oh my gosh.
I'm like not talking much.
Because I'm like so concentrated.
You know?
I'm concentrating so much.
Maybe it would be safer to go...
Back this way.
Okay.
And then I guess these have a time limit as well?
The little...
Little patches that I make?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, good thing there's a...
Checkpoint here.
Jack be nimble!
Jack be quick!
Ah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oi!
Yeah, nice!
Nice!
Oh, I can see that guy coming...
From a mile away!
Wait.
Oh, I guess there's nothing that way.
I noticed like...
It looks like there's a little path of leaves, you know?
Ow!
Oh my gosh, he's charging at me!
This tree...
I'm also like listening to the tree singing.
He's got bars.
Oh!
Oh,
uh...
No, no, no, no!
I gotta goop him up!
There we go.
This tree is spittin'.
This level is so fun!
Oh my gosh!
It's so funky!
I love it!
I mean, this whole game is so funky, but...
Yeah!
That's so cute!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, hello.
Ew, everything is so smiley.
I think you didn't want to jump into his mouth.
I mean...
You're right.
Oh, Angry Birds.
Ah!
Come here.
Collateral damage.
Scoop!
I just robbed that family.
Of all their riches.
Everybody's so happy!
What is...
What is this?
This thing...
This level is very freaky.
No wonder we found that freaky guy here.
Oh, there's more up here even.
Oh, I almost missed it.
I almost missed it.
Nice.
Bleepy!
Got a guy!
Nice, nice, nice.
I wonder who the other character is.
Maybe he's also from that...
Zombie game?
That's a lot of nuts!
How do I get up here?
Okay, hold on.
Come on.
We did it!
Oh my gosh, even like the...
Look, the indent from the balloon.
Wow.
Such attention to detail.
Smileys!
Alright, here we go.
Let's keep going.
Okay, three more.
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm so bad at this.
There we go.
Now I wait.
Oh, that was so close.
That was so close.
Woo!
Oh gosh, little poops.
What are these things?
Oh.
There we go.
These guys are new.
Oh!
Is he bad?
Bad.
But he has hard eyes.
Vankobra!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
I don't think I can...
Oh!
What do I do with these guys?
Oh no, they're platforms.
Oh no.
He loves you.
They do jump out on the beats.
It's a secret rhythm game.
Yeah!
Check behind if you miss anything.
Did I?
Oh.
Thank you.
Oh,
wait.
It won't let me slurp him.
Uh...
There we go.
It's...
This one!
It's always this one I feel.
Oh my god!
We found the other person!
Yay!
I missed a bot.
Spirit God.
You guys, I missed a bot!
Helps anyone having trouble moving.
I'm not...
I'm fine.
Where am I?
I don't need to move up.
I'm really content.
Here.
I missed one!
Where did I miss him?
But it's got...
It's between...
Here?
Oh!
Ah!
I see.
He's become...
Would you love me even if I was a worm?
Oh no.
It's putting me all the way back over here?
Wait, this sucks.
Wait, I already did this part.
Don't make me do it again.
I'll be a worm for you, girl.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm learned.
Okay,
wait.
How do I get these coins, though?
Wait, how do I get these coins, though?
Oh my gosh, I thought I was going to die!
Oh, I thought I was going to die!
I'm having a rough day.
I'm glad you're streaming because your streams always make me so happy!
I hope you're having fun playing.
I am!
Thanks, Cyberfishing!
I'm sorry, I'm having a bad day.
I hope it gets better.
It would have sent me back to the last checkpoint.
Yeah, but I would have lost the coins.
Oh, so sweet!
What's going on in here?
Honeybee!
Wow!
The blazes are so cute!
Oh my gosh!
Blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze.
Blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze!
Why do some of these look kind of mysterious?
Hmm...
Oh, I have no more charge.
Wait, hold on.
Maybe I can go get some more?
Oh wait, no.
I would have to go all the way back down.
Never mind.
So now we can suck up some honey.
Hello?
I'll take that.
Thank you.
Can I hit the breeze?
Come here.
He's like, I'm trying to work here.
Let me live my bee life.
Cute!
Oh, there's another one.
Oh, there's several of them.
Nice.
Oh, shoot.
This tree is like having his best... his best life.
He was so thirsty.
And then he got to eat me.
Ah!
I'm such a genius!
And then he got to eat me and he's really happy about it.
What a freak.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh!
Oh, I can suck up the cubes!
Ah!
Oh, wait.
Wait.
He gave me a coin, so... definitely want that.
Suck.
Gamer Minto.
Absolutely.
Ah!
Not this freak again!
Yeah!
Suck.
Suck, suck, suck.
What else could be up here though?
I've gotten like everything in this... right?
Oh, there's one more guy.
Okay.
Suck, suck, suck.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Onwards.
Assistant.
I don't like this, I don't think.
I don't think I like this.
Wait.
Why can't I just use the platforms?
Why can't I...
I'm so scared.
I don't know how to jump.
Wait.
Suck, suck.
Suck...
Okay,
since I'm here, let's just chat, I guess.
I had no honey.
It didn't...
It didn't count, it didn't count.
Okay, good.
Suck too hard.
Alright, so if we die, we gotta remember to come back here, you guys.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay, nevermind.
Why is this so hard for me?
Yeah.
This depth perception strikes again.
Okay.
Right into him, I know.
I ran out of...
I ran out of super jumping.
There we
go.
Nice.
He says my jumping skills are great.
Wait.
This is the...
This is the true boss.
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's...
This is the...
Ahh!
Mr. Depth Perception.
I know!
My depth perception.
We love our Cyclops VTuber.
For all you know, I actually need an eyepatch.
I actually have an eyepatch on.
And you're making fun of somebody that has an eyepatch!
Yeah, and I do it again.
You're so cruel!
I'm facing the wrong direction.
Wait, I'm facing the wrong way!
I'm facing the wrong way!
Checkpoint!
Delicious!
Settle the score.
What is this?
He's got a big old seam down his back.
No, he don't.
Oh, that's a lot of nuts!
What's in here?
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, that was close.
I got him!
I got the last man!
Yippee!
Yeah!
That camo looks familiar.
Look at the little bears in here.
Oh, and they're gone!
Oh my gosh, this game actually is so kind.
This game is actually so kind.
Not a bot left behind.
Nope.
How many...
Oh, and I got all the puzzle pieces.
So this world is cleared, baby.
Oh my gosh, I'm scared of this part.
The coin!
Tamatrio!
Oh shoot!
Okay, okay, I gotta get closer.
Oh, shoot.
I meant to hold it.
This music is so fun!
Oh my god!
I'm scrambling!
It's inside!
Oh, suck!
Oh my god!
I didn't jump fast enough.
That was violent, right?
Yeah, that was pretty gross.
The timing.
Lobotomize the poor egg.
Timing on this is tricky for me.
Oh my gosh!
It's okay.
I don't think I... I wouldn't call them poor birds because they're actually quite gross.
I pressed X!
I held it!
I held X!
Oh my gosh!
This part is so gross!
Okay, now here's where it gets real hard.
Oh my gosh!
There's no save spots anymore either.
What?
Yeah!
Timing!
Nice!
It sucked!
Oh my god!
There we go!
Got him!
Oh, the apples!
Is there anything special around here?
Maybe not.
Hahaha!
Oh, we just... We killed the family!
It's a lot of apples.
Where'd they all come from?
And we should have that place full complete.
Yeah!
Nice.
What's that?
No, no, no.
You.
What's you?
There's a little world.
Oh!
Special little world?
It's retro.
I don't think I went to the Retro Rampage 1!
Should we go try it out?
How do I...?
Go back.
Retro Rampage 1.
I plan on super chatting about something else.
Building a Metal Gear Gunpla with K-Sun.
Just to clarify, Dismint really only have one eye.
Retro Rampage 1.
What?
So... oh yes, I wanted to go to this one because I think there might be Katamari here, right?
Just try to be careful of rules and stuff, you know?
Regarding mentioning other people.
Unless I bring them up first.
Hello?
Oh my god!
Wait, what?
Here we go!
Okay.
Oh, why am I going against it?
Oh my gosh, this is why we're rolling!
This is so fun!
It's fun until...
Okay, don't bump into those guys.
Don't bump into those guys, everybody.
I always had a good run too.
Okay, let them come to me.
Oh my gosh.
What?
Okay.
Nice.
Come here.
Yeah.
Nice.
I'm... I'm living... I'm...
This is my calling.
This is my calling, everybody.
This is my calling!
Yes!
Clank ASMR.
Who is that?
Actually, who is it?
Oh.
Wait!
Oh!
It's a...
It's a cat!
Wait!
Oh!
What's his name?
Shiro!
Toro!
Yeah!
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
Aspirant.
Operational cat.
To purr is human.
He is so cute!
Is that...
Is that all that's there?
Okay.
Off we go!
That was so easy.
That was fun though.
I thought...
I thought 100%.
It would be Katamari.
Sorry.
We'll be better in the future.
No worries.
Thank you.
Thanks for apologizing.
I appreciate it.
You didn't have to.
But I...
I accept your apology.
Sorry.
Not that I was angry or anything.
Just wanted to kind of...
Bring that up again.
Because you know sometimes people get excited in Minecraft!
Is this what you guys are going to do to me when you get a little Lego...
Lego Minto?
Block game!
Block block game!
I want to destroy everything.
Oh my gosh.
It's so...
Guys.
This is...
It's so satisfying.
This is actually so satisfying.
Oh.
Oh!
It's so satisfying.
Oh my god!
Is that...
Discipline warrior.
Really?
Was I right?
You must defeat me.
What if we go upside down?
Okay, we can't.
We took out a tree in the process?
Okay, we're grabbing some of these little bits while we're...
These areas, though.
How mysterious.
What are we missing here?
Oh, quite a bit.
Puzzle piece.
Puzzle piece and a warp?
Okay.
What's this one?
Crumble ramble!
Let's try it out.
Raw you, as boomers say.
Crumble ramble.
What is this one now?
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is...
Wait, this one is so...
What?
This one actually looks so much fun.
It really is.
Oh.
What's that level from Fall Guys?
I'm trying not to waste as much of the board as I can.
You know?
I
don't know why this is getting me so bad now.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
We got him.
Monkey see, monkey rescue?
Home run hero!
Never afraid to take a big swing.
Oh, that was it?
So...
Okay.
That's not power pro, is it?
I don't think so.
MLB the show?
That doesn't seem like power pro.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, literally, besides these stars and then this monkey area, we're clear in this universe.
Cool.
Baseball man.
After I do this... this one?
This retro?
I want to...
Wow!
I want to do more gacha.
Oh my god.
Minecraft, my favorite retro game ever.
They ambushed me!
Wait, this is kind of freaky.
Wait, this is actually really...
What the hell?
Woah!
He, like, becomes the rabbit.
Interesting.
What if I do this?
What if I kill the rabbits first?
Ah!
Shoot!
Oh, he still becomes the metal... the metal rabbit!
You see that?
Whoa!
I don't know what I'm doing here.
I gotta watch out for the shadows.
Destroy!
The blocks!
Oh my god, I have more Street Fighter!
Assured rival.
Attack him if you dare.
Kenneth!
I keep destroying the tree.
It's Ken.
What is this cheese world over here?
Cheese to meet you.
Downsized surprise.
And then we have... Wormy Passage.
Like I said, I wanna go back real quick.
Real... right fast.
Do some more gacha a little bit, right?
Gacha though.
Yeah, we're gonna do some more gacha.
I think we probably have enough coins to finish up this.
Why doesn't Amaterasu visit me at the... at the...
At the... at the gate?
It makes me so sad.
Everybody else says hi to me.
No!
Just four more!
Everybody to your positions!
Amaterasu, why?
And also this guy, either.
Why don't you visit me?
Huh?
I'm so sorry.
The little squeak!
Never played PlayStation growing up.
Learning the culture.
Yeah!
All this history, right?
The little... so sad.
Why?
I wanted to see what happened!
Hey, guys.
I'm grabbing for ya.
I'm gonna get ya.
I'm tickling you.
I'm tickling ya.
Dog abuse.
No!
We got a banana.
Potassium pod.
Oh my god, he's cheesing that he's got this banana.
So good.
Watermelon!
Yummy.
Something to share with a new friend.
Batter's boundary.
Needs a big swinger to step up to the plate.
Oh!
He's old.
You get it?
Oh.
Ape catcher!
There's no escaping it.
The texture on this monkey.
Oh!
Wrapping cloth.
Ah!
It's so cute!
The gift that keeps on giving.
And...
Shape-shifting...
...staff.
Shape...
...shifting...
...staff.
For shepherds of restless spirits.
Oh wow, we can't clear it.
Cookie bottles!
Do they come in banana flavor?
We only have...
We still have to get more.
Deeks Drifter.
This ride is one of a kind.
Oh my god, look how cool he is.
Wow.
One more?
Unsuccessful plant.
Why won't it grow?
This is so sad.
He's actually very lame.
Oh.
This is so sad.
Okay, quit.
Actually, how do you grow a banana tree?
Huh?
How do you?
How do you plant a banana like that?
Just like that?
So he's just not being patient.
You ask it nicely.
Give me more money.
Oh.
You know what?
We'll do this one.
We can do it real quick.
Oh.
Okay.
Da-da-da-da-da.
Nana
that...
Oh.
It's cultivated nowadays.
Don't have seeds.
Bananas from grocery stores are sterile.
You have to get a cutting.
Oh.
They're sterile?
They cut off their balls?
Whoa.
No way.
It's so sad.
All right.
Look at this monkey waiting for something to do.
Sorry, guys.
I'm trying.
There's going to be like one monkey left without a job.
Oh.
What's up?
What is this?
Huh.
Have you ever seen a banana with balls?
No, because they've all been cut off.
Duh.
That's how they get them at the store.
Oh.
Okay.
We've done this one already.
Good job, everybody.
Spyro doesn't greet me either.
What's up with these guys?
They're so...
Um.
I don't know.
Snooty.
They think they're too good for me.
They give me a greeting.
Huh?
Okay.
That's fine.
Whatever.
I don't care.
Oh.
That's so cute.
Antisocial.
No.
Yeah.
They're snooty.
All right.
Let's go out and get some more guys.
And more money.
Ten gifted.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's go.
What the octopus?
What the...
Wait.
What the skango?
Oh...
Cool.
What if we try out...
Oh.
Let's try out the cheese.
Yeah.
I know.
I've missed a couple of things.
It's all good.
We'll go back and get them.
Eventually.
Thank you.
Thank you!
This music.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Sorry.
Bananas today are grown the way they are because the old kind of bananas that actually had more flavor went...
That's right!
Wait, I knew that!
That the old bananas are the... you know like the banana flavoring that is in like candies and stuff?
Yeah, that's why... that's why the banana flavoring is based off of the old bananas.
I'll be honest.
I like the new banana.
Better, I think.
Woah!
We're so tiny!
We're so small!
The banana plague.
Yeah, we lost all the other bananas.
Oh, I see them.
Oh my gosh!
I have to parkour up here?
No way!
Okay.
Look!
Oh!
This is so cute!
I
don't know why I have to be small to do this, but...
I'm in here with you!
Oh!
Very serious discussions of banana herbology in mid chat.
Yeah, I mean...
Thank you for the three... sorry.
I almost said three hundred.
For the twenty!
So much!
Oops, sorry.
Oh!
Dang it!
I got my butt zapped.
Did I get him?
Time to be small!
Wait, isn't this a guy?
Like...
Isn't...
Wait, what are you?
Oh.
What are you?
Are you not one of my robots?
Anamba.
Oh my god, wait.
I just noticed the cat.
So cute!
Can I pet the cat?
Oh, sorry.
I just tried...
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
There's coins everywhere.
Everywhere you wouldn't even expect.
Whoa!
Ah!
What are these guys doing?
Oh!
Ah!
This stage has so many small details, right?
Oh my gosh.
You guys, if I miss something...
Call me out.
Be like...
Minto!
Ah, ah...
Yodel!
Say...
Yoho!
Yodel!
Makes me wonder how much I've already missed over...
No, the potter plants probably don't have anything underneath them.
Probably.
Oh, what's in here?
Yodel!
Hmm...
Oh!
Just kidding!
Ah!
There's probably a bajillion coins here.
Punch the cheese?
I did!
Oh!
What the...
Photo spot!
That's
so cute!
Yeah!
The cats are so cute!
The reflection on them looks so good, doesn't it?
Like the reflection from their heads.
Wow!
Looks so good!
Yeah!
So cute!
Worth, worth, worth.
Oh!
Hello!
Ooh!
I forgot the plot for this the other day.
Such an unforgettable experience.
Astro is just the cutest.
Yeah!
This game is so fun.
Nice.
Wee!
Oh!
Punch him!
More coins under here?
Yeah, I'm glad though that each level doesn't also have a coin thing.
Hello?
You know how like... like a coin completion thing.
Because otherwise I'd be like...
I'd be like it's so much...
Oh my god!
Ah!
It's not the undies!
Okay, hold on everybody.
Very good!
Wee!
Oopa!
Bye!
We're in somebody's bedroom?
Are they crying?
What's wrong?
Oh!
Home invader.
I know!
Under your bed?
Oh yeah!
You got rats under your bed, man!
What if I grow big?
Nope!
Can I get under their sheets?
I'm coming in!
Make room for me though!
What's this?
Oh!
Cute!
Hello?
There we go!
Yeah, I did go underneath.
Oh!
What's this?
Wow!
Oh my god!
So cute!
I think the clock is broken.
Yeah!
Asobi!
That's what the...
You see it?
The numbers.
What do they mean?
Oh!
There's here too!
Wait.
Right?
This is a spot.
Oh!
Yes!
Hey!
What?
There's so many tiny details in this!
There's so many tiny details!
Did I get everything in the room?
I think so.
Oh!
Okay.
Onward!
Onwards!
It's a horror game all of a sudden.
You can go under the sheets?
Wait!
I can?
How do I get under the sheets?
Oh!
Wait!
Oh my god!
I almost missed him!
Thanks guys!
I have...
Oh!
I have become the freak in the sheets.
Mouse in the streets.
Freak in the sheets.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Hello!
I'm not even touching you.
I was not even looking at you.
Wait!
There's another freak in the sheets!
I want this grasshopper.
Here we go!
Who's...
Who's under here?
Oh my god!
Oh!
There's one more I think?
Yeah!
There we go!
Got it!
Oh!
Everything!
This is the worst!
That's new.
Wait!
We went to this area.
What is it?
Why is there an owl here now?
Oh!
In case you fall.
You think so?
I want to test it out.
Oh!
It really is what it is.
Yesha!
Oh!
It really is what it is.
This game is actually so kind.
It gives you...
It gives you so many...
Oh my gosh.
Depth perception.
It gives you so many...
Shortcuts and...
And...
Checkpoints.
It just makes it very...
Do you think I can go in the house?
No.
It gives you so many...
It's like this.
Chances.
Hole in the wall.
That one down there?
Hold on.
Checking any other holes in the wall.
This one?
No.
I don't see any others.
Yeah, the game is super duper user-friendly.
Yeah.
Not bad.
It's okay.
I didn't check so much, so that's why I went back to check.
Definitely easier than being a calorie mate.
No, they made it so that it could be enjoyed by literally anybody in this kind of game, you know?
Like, a baby could play this game.
I don't mean that in like a bad way, you know?
Like, it's okay.
It's so sweet.
It's such a cute game.
I'm glad that anybody can play it.
I missed one!
Oh!
Katafari!
We finally found you!
They'll make you a star!
Not on the rolling stage.
That kind of drives me insane, but I respect their decision.
Kind of drives me insane, but it's fine, I guess.
Oh!
What's this?
Wow!
Oh my god, so cute.
Oh wait, I think I need to... There we go.
Go here?
What do I do with this?
I have to blow on my controller!
Oh my god.
I...
I just...
I just yelled into it instead.
Do I jump on him?
Oh.
Okay.
I have to do it as a little baby.
Beep, boop, boop!
Oh my god!
Go back and check the cat.
I'm doing this part first.
This game is actually quite linear, so if you miss a part it's okay.
I wonder if I can get to the top.
Well, this actually works too, I think.
That works.
Oh my gosh, the squish physics are so cute.
What is that little disco?
What is that?
Ah!
You son of a...
You jerk, you!
I have to go see.
I have to go see what it is.
Up a daisy, up a daisy.
Wait,
should I go on it?
I think I should, probably.
Just so I can get it.
It's okay, we can always come back.
It's all good.
We'll get him.
Oh no.
Box'll bust it up.
Box'll bust it.
This one we also didn't complete.
Nah, he'll manage.
It's fine, it's fine.
Let's try it.
Box'll bust him.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Shoo come back for me.
I'll come back for.
I'll come back for you buddy.
Choo!
Thank you!
Ah!
Bria, you got it!
You got the choo!
Oh my gosh, these levels are so satisfying.
What's that?
Is that the moon?
No.
What are those?
These levels are so satisfying.
They're wisps?
I don't think so.
I want to just destroy everything.
I want to leave these people with no home.
Destroy everything!
Destroy, destroy!
Okay, before we go that way, let's go up.
For some reason, I always think that I can't touch those with my hands.
Oh, what the hell is that?
What?
Oh!
Forgotten mascot!
Here today, probably gone tomorrow.
Holy god!
Oh my god.
So sad.
So cute!
Oh my gosh, this game.
I can't.
I can't with how beautiful and cute it is.
It's just so lovely.
Oh.
But we got it.
I didn't realize that the green was from him.
Take that!
At least we got the puzzle piece.
Oh my god.
Tears!
Destroy, destroy!
Leave them with nothing!
Destroy!
Is that Enderman?
Come here!
What is that?
Puzzle cube.
Requires a high IQ to solve.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Rick and Morty.
I don't think there's anything else I can destroy.
Oh, I see another guy up there.
Nice.
Leave them with nothing!
Oh.
Who's in there?
Hold on.
Before we venture there.
He's right there?
Oh, my goodness.
There's a lot going on here.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
How do I use this again?
I think he, like, dashes, right?
Yeah!
There's got to be something up here.
I'm going to find it.
Whatever is up here.
Is there a warp in here?
Okay, there's another puzzle piece.
This looks breakable.
Right here.
Break it all.
Give me some to break.
About this Lego island.
It's just so addicting, you guys.
I can't stop.
It's so satisfying.
Look at this.
Look at all these cubes.
It just feels so good to destroy everything.
Oh, I left those trees.
I
don't think I got a single one.
You know what?
That's okay.
We have to go on the way back.
Whee!
Ribbon Rider likes all type of music.
I don't recognize this one either.
Oh.
They're still there.
Wait, did I go down there?
I did not.
I see a secret.
From... from, uh, beyond.
Here.
Oh!
Aha!
They want me to destroy.
See?
It's part of the game.
And...
They say...
Kill them all.
I meant Phantom.
Destroy them.
See?
This looks breakable.
Right here.
Uh...
I'm trying.
Yippee!
You're too addicted.
I know.
I'm sorry.
Oh, wait.
And that should... I think that's both puzzle pieces.
Perfect.
So now we just have one left... one guy left.
And then...
That should be it.
Oh!
Oh my
gosh.
Oh!
That was so close!
So... close.
Nature healed.
No!
Save!
How do you... You don't even have a mouth!
You don't even have a mouth!
Oh my god.
There he is.
I'm gonna go back and do it all over again.
Little do you guys know that...
When I'm not streaming...
Where do you think I'll be?
Destroying the planet.
This is my safe zone.
This is my calming area now.
Frustrating stream?
No, I'm not anymore.
I'll just think about all these little trees.
Burst into blocks.
Ah, yeah.
The
house is too cute.
One voxel tree at a time.
Exactly.
Oh!
Wait.
Haha!
No!
Full-starred that one.
Yeah, gold... gold-crowned it.
This one, we're missing a puzzle piece.
I don't feel like doing a run.
I don't remember how to get here.
Oh, I go to the... to the...
The dimension.
Okie dokie.
Uh, we were being cheesed.
Right?
Yeah, yeah.
We gotta go back to the cheese world, everybody.
You missed a few blocks to destroy.
Thank you!
Oh, no.
I have to get all the coins again.
It's ok.
I feel like we were pretty far in the...
I think...
I think this is the only one that's kind of annoying to...
do again because...
I feel we got so far in...
Like, it was so much.
What do you mean I don't have to?
I didn't beat the level, you guys!
Even if I had gotten that one guy...
I didn't beat the level.
There was still another guy that I needed to get.
The shortcut with the owl.
Oh.
I don't think so.
Because everything is still here.
Or here again, rather.
Oh, my god.
I pressed the wrong button.
But
I get more coins.
So, ok.
Yeah.
So, it's kind of like...
Why not?
Kind of get them, you know?
You can just run past everything.
But I get more gacha stuff.
So, it's like...
I don't...
Why not?
It's just...
I just gotta run through it real quick.
You know?
I don't know.
I just gotta run through it real quick.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Did I get in here?
This is where I got the guy.
Right?
Gacha brain.
It's ok.
We know all their secrets.
I probably won't get every single one, but...
I can destroy this even!
Oops.
Sorry, cat.
I'm sorry, cat.
I'm sorry.
See you, dog.
Look, I'm a speedrunner.
I'm a speedrunner, you guys.
That was some speedrunning strategy.
What's this one again?
Tiny.
Oh, wait.
I don't think I did this before.
I missed this.
I thought it was just a tiny...
I thought it was just a tiny coin, but no.
There's a whole thing in there.
Min-maxing her runs for coins and her gacha game.
She's highly experienced.
Truly.
See?
Actually, it was worse.
It was worse!
I think I'm gonna sneeze.
What?
Okay.
I see you.
Grab these.
Bless you.
Thank you!
All the
vandalism.
Now that I know I can destroy stuff and get... See?
These are speedrun strats.
If you want to get the coins still.
You gotta destroy the stuff to get it.
Do you think if I follow that way, I'll be down?
Do you think it leads to anywhere?
See how there's like a little groove down there?
Now this kind of stuff I'm not gonna... You know, I don't need to do that again.
I like how there's little... It's like, hello!
Worth checking out.
Is it though?
Shut up.
Grab these.
Perfect.
Looks like it has potential.
Right!
Damn it.
Stop
eating the cheese!
Um...
Alright, we're just about back to where we were at before.
This is great.
Under the bed?
Oh, it's okay.
I'm not gonna get every...
If I miss a spot, it's okay.
I'm not gonna be too concerned about it.
Thanks for the coins!
I just... I did get to watching...
Oh, escape from New York!
Give it a 4 out of 5.
Nice!
It's so good, right?
Escape from New York.
Snake Plissken.
There we go.
Oh, I missed a coin over there.
But I give up.
Money!
A rat broke in and stole my coins.
And then broke everything.
And also ate my homework.
Wait, I get to do this part again!
Okay.
It just spat all over my controller.
You guys, the cat is to proceed.
We gotta get this guy first.
I don't know why you guys are so like...
The cat!
We gotta do this guy first.
My controller is all broken.
Wait, do I just...
Oh, I have to do the same thing as before.
Where I go in and blow it up.
Okay, just kidding.
I don't know why I'm so silly.
There we go.
Cute Vtuber playing cute game.
The stresses of the week are melting away.
Also spit, Tatsuka.
I can't...
I can't blow normally, I think.
I think...
Because whenever I...
Actually, I had someone make fun of me for it before.
When I was like blowing a dandelion, you know?
I would go like...
They'd be like, why don't you do that normally?
Wait, there was a guy there.
He's probably upset I'm destroying his home.
Yeah!
Anything over here?
Anything of value?
All right.
Shoo!
And big!
Wait, is that...
Oh, I thought that mouse had panties on its head.
I'd be like, I love this game.
Oh, just kidding.
Mouse is just like me, for real, for real.
Oh, this is like...
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
Depth perception, please!
This game...
This is now like true platforming.
This is...
There we go.
Easy.
Nice.
There we go.
This feels so classic, doesn't it?
Oh!
Don't get me.
Ah!
He's yelling.
Ow!
I got you!
I think.
Far
rescued!
Intrepid rodent.
She's a real page turner.
Long live the king.
How much more?
Okay, we have one more puzzle piece.
Somewhere.
Okay.
Oh!
Alright.
Where...
If I were a puzzle piece...
Okay.
Thanks.
Where would I be if I were a puzzle piece?
Where would I be?
Somewhere...
Oh!
Where would I be?
Back down?
Did I miss?
Oh!
Okay.
Back down below.
Oh!
Uh...
Okay.
Um...
Don't grab.
Okay.
Ah!
Ouch!
I'll leave.
Ow!
Um...
Inside the tower...
You know, I was thinking that maybe...
Um...
Like, in between the cogs, there would be something.
But I couldn't turn my...
I was afraid of dying.
In between...
Look up from the balcony.
I see!
Oh my god!
It's so...
I can't believe I missed it.
That's so funny.
Where is it?
Come on, hand!
Gamers don't look up.
It's so true!
Birdhouse is the end of the level.
That's what I thought.
Which is why I was like...
Wait a second.
I don't want to go in there yet.
Oh!
I'm going to have to fight some...
And we'll have completed this one too.
100%.
Oh!
Why are you...
Why are you getting hard eyes?
I'm a little...
Ow!
No!
I have to wait for it to go all the way back around.
No way!
Can you just become big?
Did I get it?
Nope.
It's like making my controller vibrate so much.
How was your day, Min?
It was okay.
It's alright.
Oh!
I don't know if you use Twitter.
For those who do, you might have saw.
But actually...
Oh gosh!
Dang it!
Stop!
I think from there, I just have to jump.
I think I...
But my official happy coat is...
I don't know.
Like actually, I got a sample of it today.
It's so soft.
It's so nice.
But...
Jump hover.
Yeah.
But...
The pre-orders for it will be up on...
I think Monday.
Earth coin!
Thanks to the 5 gifted!
Should be up on...
Up on Monday.
I, of course, will post the information when it is.
Oh gosh!
Okay.
As soon as I feel like I can.
Yeah!
Okay.
I believe that...
I was told that they'll probably ship around end of the year.
As for my other merch that I announced during my anniversary, I still have that in the works.
Plushies are being produced now and I will be working with a place to...
As like my store and as fulfillment and stuff like that.
So it won't be me doing it myself.
You're welcome, everybody.
And maybe some other stuff in the works as well.
So...
Excited for it.
Oh!
Big!
Wait, there was no boss in this level.
Seven guys.
Yeah!
So...
Oh!
Nice!
So, yeah!
I'm working on all of that.
Hmm.
And yeah!
Beep!
Nice!
So we have this one.
Oh my gosh!
Check the meteor!
Nah!
Let's go to...
Wormy Passage!
Yippee!
The more you spam something, the more I'm not gonna wanna do it.
Maybe you're new here.
Ah!
Shoot!
No!
I wanted to go...
Hold on.
I wanna restart.
I wanna go to that one.
Oh!
I don't think I can...
Never mind.
Ooh!
Oh!
I'm not good at these types of things.
Wait!
Ah!
Got it!
Oh!
It's these guys!
Ja!
Yeah!
Take that!
Hi!
Little weasels!
Take that!
Who's that over there?
Oh my god!
Ooh!
That was close!
Ow!
Oh my...
He ate my hand!
Why are they flexing?
Huh?
Don't think about eating peanut butter.
I've never once thought about eating peanut butter before.
Wait!
Is this the...
Life is...
No.
I thought this...
Is this...
Oh!
Wait!
Immune service...
Is this...
Oh!
This is...
Last of Us?
Right?
Ellie...
Yeah!
From Last of Us?
Aspires to be an astronaut.
Yes!
I know!
Can I climb these?
I'm gonna punch this guy's teeth in.
Just like my grandma taught me.
One!
Two!
Three!
Four!
Uh...
I gotta give him the old, like, seven-eight.
Yahoo!
Oh!
Oh, gosh.
We'll get his butt.
His butt!
Yeah!
I got his butt.
This is like the most obvious puzzle piece ever.
Bolt to bits.
Whoa!
We are changing the ecosystem.
Oh!
Oh,
my gosh.
That was so close.
Yeah!
I'll take that.
Checkpoint.
Thank you.
But what is this?
Maybe I shouldn't have taken it.
Oh!
I gotta smash him.
Level music is a bop.
There we go.
Got his butt.
This guy has so many injuries on him.
Hold on!
Gosh!
You're so close!
You're so needy!
Like a cat in heat!
Stop!
They sound like Blue from Blue's Clues, you know?
I don't know why I thought that was...
Oh, okay.
I got everything here.
Cool.
Okay.
We got this.
Look!
Nice.
They're so wiggly-jiggly.
Oh!
What?
I touched a cactus!
No way!
Nice!
No!
Best song so far.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's like very chill.
I do like it.
Okay.
Let's go
to the cactus route today.
Whoa!
Wait.
Let's go the cactus route first since I think this is the way we're supposed to go.
This guy has got his cheeks full.
Wait!
This is...
Is this the guy from Last of Us 2?
Dependable smuggler?
Tells the occasional white lie?
Is this also the guy from Last of Us?
Okay.
No.
This part is Joel.
You know, I've never played or seen Last of Us before.
How am I supposed to time this part?
He's the second to last one.
Missed one.
Oh, I did?
Oh?
Oh, I hear someone.
Oh!
Oh.
I got him.
Thanks, guys.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
I did miss one.
I didn't even notice because I was so like...
I was like, Last of Us.
Thank you, guys.
Okay.
This part...
I don't know.
What?
How...
Am I supposed to...
It was so easy.
There we go.
Yippee!
Whoa!
Ow!
Gross!
Come here, baby!
Keep sucking.
Keep sucking my fingers.
Maybe I need both fists.
I like
their little dances.
Yeah, I did that.
That was a little weird, but thanks!
That's probably how they're feeling right now.
They're like, Oh!
Bye, captain.
Bye!
Just have to say it like that.
Coins first.
Oh, oh, oh!
Coins first!
Ha, ha, ha!
Oh!
There's a guy in here!
Hahaha!
You're welcome!
Oh!
I remember this.
Ah!
Ha!
I made it somehow.
I feel like it's just barely, though.
I feel like I'm moving on.
Nice shot, thank you.
I'm a good gamer.
You really mean that?
Why is this guy mushroomed out?
Oh is he a little zombie fungus head?
Don't give them a chance to grow on you.
Oh we are infecting all the other robots.
What?
I guess we'll die.
I don't know.
Oh well.
Making sure I didn't miss anything.
What have you done?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Is there anything else in there?
I don't think I saw anything else.
The chambered nautilus.
Yeah, they're cute, aren't they?
How many more guys do we have?
Just the one.
Okay.
We have them all y'all.
1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14.
Hahaha.
The AI thinks you're playing The Last of Us.
I mean, I can understand that.
We've been talking about it.
Yeah, get yourself ready.
Oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot.
Ah, that was close.
Woo, we killed the man and he blew up.
It was so beautiful.
We're missing one though.
I can't, I cannot continue onward.
We're missing one.
Is it you?
Go forward.
But, but, but, but our last guy.
Go ahead?
Okay.
Is it because it'll be a big old boss?
Oh, oh, oh, ahhh!
Oh, gross.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's actually really... Oh, it's so squishy!
The heartbeat!
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh, it's so fast!
It's so fast!
Okay, okay.
I hate these levels.
They stress me out more than like...
anything.
Like I know...
I know everything...
needs like a time level, you know?
I get it.
But...
I'm not good with these kinds of things!
Ewww!
Wait...
I think I'm supposed to...
Launch!
There we go.
I
think we also...
Oh, 100% of this one.
I love baby games.
They make me feel good.
They make me feel like I can accomplish things.
Alright, now I'm gonna go check out...
Wait, this is the same meteor I did earlier!
It didn't even change into anything!
I literally did this...
Oh!
Lost triangle, boy!
Why did it go from being a...
From being a circle to a triangle?
Oh my gosh!
It's like the paperclip!
Wow...
Everything is triangle.
Are there people here?
Nothing, no?
Just a triangle.
Can you follow the triangle path?
Okay.
How Metal Gear Delta of them, yeah.
Oh!
Clippy?
Yeah, yeah, Clippy!
I'm gonna hit all four of them.
Never mind.
They're coming with.
Clippy!
What are these now?
What?
Cut and grind...
What the...?
What are these?
Oh, shit!
Oh my God!
Oh...
Oh, okay!
Okay.
This one is kind of tough.
That was close.
Rookie cop!
Worst first day on the job ever!
Leon!
Where's Tri, baby?
Is that the only thing there?
Yeah, it sure is.
Is there anything left here?
Nope.
Just a bunch of stars.
Dashing Dillo?
That one was freaky though.
I was kind of stressed in that last one.
I'm not gonna lie.
I was stressed in there.
Oh!
Ow!
It's the Persona!
Okay.
I think we can do this one.
What the hell?
Someone died here!
Oh.
I lost my Armadillo?
Leave him.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh,
wait a second.
This is too much.
There's more!
Oh my god!
There's another De- Sorry.
Sorry.
Yay!
Adorable shadow!
Catch them on the midnight channel!
This is Persona 4, right?
That's the midnight channel, right?
Epic Gamer Minto.
Thank you!
Teddy!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
True gamer.
That one stressed me out.
I think even more.
My goodness.
Known as Kuma in Japan.
Pumpkin Peril!
Pumpkin!
These ones are- I don't like them.
Well, I like them.
But they're supposed to scare me so much.
Who's here?
Oh!
Other Resident Evil girl?
I can't remember her name.
Oh.
Wait, how am I supposed to defeat these guys again?
I don't remember.
Claire!
God.
Okay.
My timing is a little...
Puncher Leo?
I just punched him?
Okay, okay.
I defeated all the other ones.
First try for me to reach the top.
Zero this one.
I just have to be more patient.
But I...
Oh
my gosh.
Okay.
This one's tricky.
It's even like ice skating.
So it's like...
Oh my gosh!
It's not even just like a normal like you...
Are there, you know?
It's like also.
It's like a skating aspect to...
What the heck is this?
Oh my god!
Ahhh!
Oh my god.
This is awful.
Oh my gosh.
Give me a break.
I have to save a heart, girl.
Save the heart.
Wait, I have to skate?
Okay, so that's ice.
Oh my gosh, and then I have to make sure I'm not on the electric... Oh my god!
This is so hard!
Stop!
Okay.
Hot babe at the top of the tower.
The fact that this one doesn't even give you a break because you're dealing with this guy.
Oh my gosh.
I thought the hot babe was at the bottom right of my screen.
Stop it!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, we made it.
Sniped, I know, right?
This is really... This is how you get used to the game.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I can't see anything.
I can't... My depth perception, you guys.
My depth perception.
No, please.
Please.
Kill, kill, kill.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're back to where we were before.
These triangle levels are no joke.
What the... No!
He didn't shoot!
Oh, what?
No way.
No!
Yeah, he didn't even shoot though.
I think I ran into him.
I think I ran into him and that's what happened.
I think
I ran into him and that's what happened.
I think I'm going to ignore the jelly guy, yeah.
I was a faster.
I think I'm going to try ignoring the jelly guy, yeah.
Oh shoot.
This level is so tricky!
I'm going to be so good at the game after this.
There's spikes there!
I gasped.
More for XO to compliment the controller buttons.
Yeah, no, I believe that.
But I'm also shocked why am I...
I haven't used the triangle button even once in this challenge.
So much for celebrating the triangle button.
But it doesn't even use the triangle... triangle button.
Got him!
Okay.
Joy!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the prank!
Thank you, thank you.
I don't think they... okay.
Ignore him.
I'm scared of this part!
I did not like the baby games.
Damn!
Thank you so much for the tiny gift attack!
Thank you!
What makes you think they're going to make you use the triangle?
You're right.
Nothing.
Good luck!
Thank you!
Okay, I'm going to come back to this planet.
I want to see this one though, real quick.
I'm curious.
Fragile Frenzy.
Let's see what this one's like.
Oh!
I guess...
I want...
Okay.
I was greedy.
But it's okay.
Oh my gosh.
How am I supposed to do that part?
Hmm...
Hold on.
I'm going to test something real quick.
I'm just going to go for it.
Don't double jump?
Do they break with you just stepping on them?
Oh!
They don't!
All
right!
Hot mo!
Thank you for the hot mo!
We're not talking about this square.
Or this...
Circle?
Or this X?
We're talking about this triangle!
Oh my gosh.
Johnny Bravo, are you into pear shapes?
Thank you so much!
Thank you for the hot mo!
Thank you!
My
bad.
I need to just do what I do at the beginning.
For these.
So here...
I can just... yeah.
Oh my gosh.
All right.
Here.
Doritos shaped woman.
My beloved.
Put all the waifu behind the challenge level.
Right.
Keep going.
I'm trying.
Oh suck.
I know what I have to do.
I don't know what to do there, though.
Do I not get that thing because it falls down?
I guess that kind of sucks.
But this one, I guess I can double jump.
It just is also scary, this level.
Why would I think otherwise?
Delta!
Oh my gosh.
How am I supposed to get past the poops?
They're all going to spit on me.
Okay.
I'll be honest.
I don't think I'm in the mood for challenges anymore.
We got past two of them.
I think I'm tired.
I think I'm tired, you guys.
I'm not going to lie.
I think we've gone through enough of them.
I think I've gone through enough of them.
We can do them next time, maybe.
Let's try the boss.
Oh, what was that over there?
Baby game.
Yeah, baby game.
Get this guy.
Yeah,
that's right.
Are we going to face off against that guy again?
Oh my gosh.
The Kraken?
Go back and continue the Redfield bloodline.
Easy.
Is there anything up there?
I know it said that there was two guys in here.
Wait a second.
I think there's someone behind here.
Looks pretty flimsy.
Never mind.
I lied.
Here.
Looks flimsy.
Your...
Ship is...
lacking.
It's a shipwreck.
Punchy punch.
Oh, I guess that's our arena down over there, huh?
There's some coins.
I'll take that.
Don't tell her about the boss.
No, I know there's...
I know there's two of them.
I just don't know where they are.
Looking around.
Anything that I could have committed?
Never mind.
That's where I came from.
Boss stages don't have secrets?
Oh.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh.
I have two guys...
Two spirits following me.
What does this mean?
Wait.
What does this mean, actually?
Not the tentacles!
Let's see if I have this with the anime called the tentacles.
No!
Baku taku!
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
That was fast.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my gosh.
Nice!
That should take care of him a little bit.
Why does it sound like an elephant?
And...
Latch!
Never
mind.
I don't punch there.
No!
I thought because it had the symbol, I thought I would punch there to like...
Oh!
That's okay.
You do punch there!
Must be two hands then, probably.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
So you get three lives on me.
Nice.
Underneath.
Oh!
That's why I have the two things behind me.
I get it now.
I thought it was for the two robots that I was going to be rescuing.
Hahaha.
Oh!
That was a little bit...
Man, you can do it.
Ouch!
Those ones are hard to avoid.
Punch!
Oh!
Damn it!
What?
How am I supposed to...
I don't understand that one at all.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Okay.
Punch harder.
Yeah.
I dread.
Uh...
Also, don't miss.
Okay.
Solid advice.
Under the ground.
Okay.
Now this one is when he...
Sucks up.
He sucks.
Okay.
Nice!
Oh, oh, so is he.
Oh, that's how you probably do it faster, huh?
And this side.
Concussion!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
What's happening?
This is so much.
I'm scared!
I'm scared of this part!
I don't like the sounds it's making!
Ouch!
I don't like the sounds!
Like the...
It's scary.
Nasty!
Oh my god, the music finished so perfectly.
Hey!
Summer vacation.
Um...
What's that?
A rescue boat?
This is a... Oh, it's God of War!
How hard is your head?
Really, really, really hard.
And craters!
I rescued a baby.
He's just throwing us around.
John, God of War.
Yeah, pretty much.
Alright, hold on tight, little baby!
Woohoo!
I love that you can see us flying and like...
Wobbling around.
Yay!
We did it!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice!
What is that?
Oh!
You guys aren't going home with us?
What did you... Oh!
Oh, it's a puzzle piece!
Come here.
Got it.
What is this?
What's the timer?
Oh!
Interesting.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
So I gotta wait for that guy.
Hey, why didn't you come home with us?
Well...
Let's go back and do some catch-up.
Dive on in.
Guys, when do I get the more Metal Gears?
Gotcha time.
And I need two!
Let's go.
And...
Yay!
World three.
Okay.
Splash my dash.
The Dual Speeder Garage is open!
Get in and give your Dual Speeder a whole new look!
Oh, this must be outfits!
Oh my gosh.
Let's go check out our thing.
No!
Oh, I only have two colors.
Wow!
Fancy.
Okay, we gotta get more colors.
This game is huge.
I know, right?
I know.
I mean, I would hope so.
I mean, I was...
Cost of like a...
You know...
A game.
Cost of a game.
We got our gamer.
Those must be more colors.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
You guys!
I don't think we're gonna...
The Rolex Star!
So cute!
Sticks to everything.
Oh my god!
I don't think we're gonna be able to pull everything, but...
Irresistible bait!
I got scammed twice in a row.
Wow!
It's so cute!
Oh, those are all colors.
I got an uncomfortable couch.
Okay.
Wipeout.
Oh!
Travel bag and distracting masonry.
Helps to avoid unwanted attention.
It's just a prank.
You can avoid unwanted attention by...
By murdering them.
Couldn't sleep so now I'm here.
Hi everyone.
Hello!
Sorry you can't sleep.
Oh!
We...
I got all the stuff for the apes.
Let's go.
You don't look so well off as...
Oh!
He's like, excuse me.
I'm trying to figure out this puzzle.
It's so cute.
Hahaha!
It's so cute!
Cube washer.
Stressful.
Looks kind of like Otakon.
No!
Game changing relic.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh!
It's so funny.
It's just a little...
A little decoration.
Paranormal TV!
Try not to get too sucked in by it.
The channel's not working though.
Jade blade and storybook.
Which one was this again?
Survival kit.
Oh my gosh.
Ellie looks so sad.
Make enemies quiver in fear.
I think she's the one quivering.
Moss.
Oh.
Last one.
Oh!
Striking scarlet.
This color's ultra man.
Hahaha!
Ultra man!
I want the ultra man one, I think.
Wow, our little...
Our little planet is becoming so lively, isn't it?
Little big planet.
Yeah.
We can grab some more coins.
I think we'll be able to do one more if we grab these two.
Yep.
Okay, let's go do one more.
Hmm.
One more.
Gotcha!
Hahaha!
Punch the katamari.
Oh, I will.
No, no, no!
I'm gonna get the Pepsi!
Oh!
Shimmering silver.
Reflects your star...
Wow!
So shimmery.
My first instinct being a VTuber was like, uh-oh.
Reflection.
Hahaha!
That was...
That was my first instinct.
Let's go see everybody else.
Oh my gosh.
This is kind of awful.
Oh!
Hahaha!
It's cosplay!
I didn't know I'm mean.
Oh!
Remember how I mentioned...
Ah!
Killing somebody?
Don't.
Everybody's got a little thing.
Look at all these monkeys.
Oh!
I wish that the monkeys weren't all just like... you hit them and they just knock off their head and all.
So...
Woo!
Oh!
Freaky!
Wow!
Oh!
Oh no!
Hahaha!
Out of the park.
This one's so cute.
Oh!
Ah!
Hahaha!
So cute!
Oh no, the butterfly.
Have we tried all of them now, I believe?
Gosh, these are so cute.
I can't!
No, let's go with the Ultraman one.
It's so awesome.
I also really like this one, though.
Oh!
Can I really make it?
I really like this one.
It's a red one.
If you break it, you buy it.
No!
I didn't break anything!
It looks like gamer stuff.
What?
The... the building?
I think I got all of them now.
Oh wait.
Where did you come from?
Oh my god.
Oh, I made her angry!
Oh, she's chasing the chicken.
That's what's going on.
Oh!
They're
so cute!
I'm starting to get sleepy, you guys.
Oh my gosh!
It's been four hours!
Well, we completed a whole world too!
Maybe... Hold on, let's go back in.
Maybe... Depending... I don't have any plans to super 100% the game.
But maybe I guess then about three-ish more streams or so.
Because then we do one... Maybe I can try and do one world per stream.
Um...
So...
Yeah, we'll see.
Three... or rather four...
Three more or four more because maybe I'll...
I don't know.
I might have so much fun that I just end up trying to 100% it after all.
And I need to go back and get some guys from like here.
I'm missing... I'm missing... or puzzle pieces, I mean.
Am I... I'm missing...
Yeah, I'm missing... Actually, I'm missing quite a few from here.
Yeah, I'm missing...
Actually, I'm missing quite a few from here.
Aren't all metal gears?
Yes.
What am I... I'm missing...
Where am I... Oh, I'm missing from the triangle?
Oh... Oh, in here!
Oh, I'm missing a ton from here.
Okay, yeah, I gotta do the bot of war.
I forgot about this one.
I was like, wow, I'm missing so many.
Wait, this is all...
They're all PlayStation characters.
You'll want to 100% the whole game.
She's totally gonna 100% this game.
I'd want to 100% if it weren't aggravating, which this doesn't look.
No, no, this game is quite forgiving, honestly.
And it helps that the... even if the boss battles or some of the battles are a little challenging, they're not very long.
So it's not like... it's not like a chore to get back to where you were, you know?
Hmm...
So, yeah...
This is so fun!
I hope you guys are enjoying it so far.
I so much am.
I'll probably do some more next week as well.
And yeah, only the symbol stages seem rage-inducing.
I got through the first two, not so bad.
But the next two are gonna be... oof.
Thanks for the comfy stream on my birthday!
Bria, happy birthday!
Thank you to you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Bria!
I hope I sang your name right.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
I'm also hungry, so I'm gonna go get a little bit of a snack.
I didn't really have dinner, so...
Thank you guys again!
And yeah, I'll see you guys next time...
When I play!
Tomorrow I'm playing Metal Gear Solid 3.
Continuing that.
And um...
I want pizza!
I wish I could remember that the show wasn't too late for pizza.
Chill!
Thanks for the fun stream!
Honestly, 2024 has been a crazy year for VTubers, so I just wanna say thank you for being Minto.
Yeah!
Has been a crazy year, huh?
TryPrincess, thank you!
Thank you!
Has been a really crazy year, huh?
Yeah...
But, I can say...
At least for myself...
Um...
I...
I'm very hopeful about things that I'm doing in the future.
After so much overtime, I finally made it for a livestream.
JollyRatRotter!
Thank you!
Hope to find John A's combat next time.
Me too.
Um...
Hmm...
You know...
Um...
I hope that...
Uh...
You know...
Despite there having been so many...
I guess strange?
Uh...
So many changes?
So many changes...
I was gonna say strange things...
I mean...
The whole concept of VTubers is strange.
But...
Despite so many changes, I hope that you guys still feel...
Um...
Excited about...
Following VTubers and...
Um...
You know...
I hope that...
It hasn't really...
You know...
When...
Things like this happen...
The first thing I think about are just like...
How the fans...
Are...
And if they're okay...
Cause...
You know...
It...
It is...
It's not...
It's not an ideal situation...
So...
I just hope that...
Everybody is okay...
And...
Especially in this situation...
It's a lot of...
It's a little bit...
It feels like a little bit of limbo...
Um...
Since everybody is kinda confused...
About what's going on...
Uh...
But...
I think from...
I was watching her stream...
Earlier...
It doesn't seem so...
Negative...
And uh...
I think about...
Um...
I guess...
I don't know if it really applies...
In this situation...
But...
Um...
How...
Uh...
Maybe...
Maybe it doesn't apply...
Maybe I won't bring it up...
There was something that...
An idol...
Oshii of mine...
Brought up before...
But I don't think it really applies here...
Though...
I just say it because...
It was when she announced...
Her graduation...
That she kind of...
Talked about it...
But...
Um...
Uh...
I just...
You know...
Speaking from experience...
When someone makes...
A decision like this...
It's not easy...
And it's...
It's honestly like...
Uh...
It feels like...
Um...
I wouldn't say a last resort...
But...
You know...
It has...
It's like...
Okay...
This is truly what's best for me...
And so...
You know...
Um...
That's why...
You know...
Trust in your Oshii...
Believe in your Oshii...
That...
They're doing what's best for themselves...
And...
I know it hurts...
I know it's really hard...
Especially to...
Um...
Accept...
As a teammate...
Your streams helped today...
Minto...
I'm glad...
Thank you...
Um...
To be honest...
I'm just so sad about it...
Um...
But...
Like...
I don't wanna...
Um...
I...
I can't imagine how...
The members themselves are feeling...
So...
But...
Right now...
She needs...
Support from everybody...
And...
I know...
That everybody is giving that to her...
And...
Um...
Just always one of those reminders...
Like...
To...
Um...
Cherish...
The times...
That are fun...
You know...
With Hiroshi...
And...
Um...
All those fun memories...
That you made with her...
Are...
Always going to stay...
And you can always look back...
And...
Think how fondly...
You know...
Especially...
With...
With Myth...
How much they...
Um...
Made...
Covid...
So much less...
Lonely...
I'm very grateful for that...
And...
Uh...
We got all those...
We were...
We were really lucky...
To have...
As much time...
With her...
As we did...
So...
And...
Uh...
Hopefully...
We see her again...
Somehow...
In another capacity...
Whatever...
She does...
Uh...
Since it's kind of vague...
Yeah...
And...
Of course...
You know...
One thing...
As well is...
Things have to change...
To move forward...
So...
We can also look forward to...
All the fun things that will happen in the future...
All the fun events that will be happening...
And...
Um...
New people that we'll meet...
And...
Everything that...
That...
You know...
Comes with...
Moving forward and...
Having things change...
In our...
Lives...
And after lives...
Yeah...
So...
You know...
I do hate saying goodbyes though...
It's one of my least favorite things ever...
And...
I have...
I have full...
Like...
Uh...
I guess...
Faith in her...
I know that she's...
Got such a good head on her shoulders...
She's so...
Talented...
So creative...
So everything...
You know...
We all know that...
These traits about her...
So...
Whatever she...
Is...
Decides to do...
Will be...
Really...
Really awesome...
And...
I hope it all works out for her...
Cooper!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
It doesn't have to be goodbye...
It can be a bon voyage...
Yeah...
Exactly...
No...
VTuber should stay the same forever...
But if things stay the same forever...
You can't ever appreciate the things...
You know?
But I don't want to say goodbye to yesterday...
We have to...
Say bye to things...
To be able to...
To appreciate...
Why we...
Love those things...
To begin with...
You know?
Otherwise...
Otherwise if things stay the same forever...
You'll just...
Kind of get bored of it...
Right?
You'll...
End up...
You'll be like...
This is fun!
And...
You know...
Eventually you'll be like...
Oh...
I don't know...
I never knew how much fun it was...
So yeah...
See you next time!
Bye!
Stay strong, teammates!
And...
Give her lots of support!
Thank you, Mr. Sante!
I needed to hear this!
Yeah!
Of course it sucks!
And you're...
Totally valid in...
Feeling sad...
You know?
So don't feel like you have to be like...
So happy positive!
It's okay to feel your feelings!
No matter what they say...
And don't let people discredit that!
Don't let people say like...
Oh, you should be...
Thinking this way or that way...
You're totally valid in...
You know...
Even to people that don't understand VTubers...
You know?
Or...
Understand VTubers...
To people that don't understand VTubers...
You know?
There's always that discussion...
They're like...
People could treat...
I know this isn't a graduation...
But they're like...
People treat VTubers leaving their graduations as like they're dying!
But...
You know?
It's...
It's not the same...
When...
Someone leaves...
Uh...
You're...
You're leaving...
They're leaving a whole...
Like...
Group of people...
A whole...
Uh...
You don't get those same interactions anymore?
Like...
It's...
It is like a character is dying!
Yeah!
Essentially...
Thank you Mint for being here!
Anime MYC made me want to start watching you again!
Sorry I didn't go to the concert!
I'm sorry!
Thank you so much!
Happy to have you here!
Someone once told me...
If nothing breaks, nothing moves.
And it took me a long time to understand it...
But I think about it a lot nowadays.
Yeah!
I think...
You know...
As...
Sad as...
It is...
To say...
You know...
Goodbye to...
Certain things...
Um...
It's exciting to look forward to...
What will come next...
So...
Hmm...
And through...
Through strife...
Comes innovation!
You know?
And...
Uh...
Not only giving...
You know...
Amelia...
Her support...
But also...
The Myth members...
All the other...
Hollow Iyan members...
I'm sure they're kind of all feeling...
Um...
A lot right now...
So...
Hmm...
Let's just...
Uh...
All be really supportive...
And...
You know...
All emotions are valid...
While mourning...
People go through it...
In their own ways...
So don't feel ashamed...
Of feeling certain ways...
Exactly!
Tough time...
Never lasts...
Only tough people...
Last...
I can't say that...
You know...
My...
Situation...
Is the same as hers...
Obviously...
By having...
You know...
Done similar stuff...
But...
It's...
It's really hard...
It's like the hardest decision...
I was feeling...
You know...
I couldn't sleep at all last night...
Really much...
Because of...
I saw it...
Right before I went...
Like the announcement...
Right before I went to bed...
And I was like...
I was just up...
You know...
Just thinking about so many things...
Like I was like...
Thinking about all the fans...
And I was thinking about...
All the members...
And I was...
Thinking about...
My own situation...
And I was just feeling...
Uh...
Like a deja vu...
It like...
Brought so many feelings back to me...
So I was like...
Whoa...
Not necessarily good feelings...
You know...
So it's like...
I was listening to an archive of one of your karaoke...
When I beat a boss...
I was struggling with an Elden Ring...
Cheers!
A bito!
Wow!
Congrats Lali!
You know...
I was like...
Lali-pop!
Oh!
Lali-la-la-la-la-la-la-lali-pop!
Lali-pop!
Oh!
Lali-la-la-la-la-la-la-lali-pop!
Yeah!
So...
Uh...
Yeah!
I hope you guys are feeling okay...
And...
Yeah...
Sorry...
I didn't mean to talk so much about it...
Okay!
Thank you guys for hanging out with me!
Bye!
I will see you guys...
When I see you next...
Atsumita!
Have a good day!
Have a good night!
Ittarashou!
I'll see you guys in the main cafe...
Next time I...
See you!
Bye bye!
Oh!
My computer is acting weird...
Bye bye!
Thank you!
See you!
Bye bye!